madeleine blé morin et christian dufour
alec castonguay bonsoir courtois tour de
table on va parler du français beaucoup
et de ce qui se passe à ottawa mais
d'abord tour de table sur ces fameux
congé des fêtes ici au québec en ontario
n'a dit nous on ne va pas les allonger
ça a été dit aujourd'hui au québec vous
savez qu on jongle avec donc ajouter une
ou deux semaines
quelques jours avant quelques jours
après idéalement voyez les lits scénario
avant après dr verra les deux un peu
avant pour protéger la parenté qui après
pour protéger l'école
qu'est ce que vous en pensez de tout
cela alex d'abord heureux de vous
retrouver
bonsoir vous étiez en train d'écrire un
livre qu'on va lire avec avec beaucoup
beaucoup de joie bientôt on à repeindre
une autre fois mais bref les congés
janet oued
je pense que karl weiss a raison c'est à
dire qui des allemands et si c'était le
scénario privilégié au gouvernement que
de déposer une espèce de zone tampon une
quarantaine d'heures sans dire avant et
après parce qu'on va voir davantage de
contacts sociaux dans le temps de noël
donc pour protéger un peu tout le monde
là on semblait du côté du gouvernement
pencher davantage vers une fermeture
après seulement dans les derniers jours
ce que surpris un peu les spécialistes
en zambie
ce serait bien qu'on arrive en bonne
position à noël non pas qu'on fasse
juste réparé les dégâts après et donc
qu'est ce que le gouvernement va jongler
avec soin la décision impôts tout à fait
pris encore il ya un gros point
d'interrogation sur qu'est ce que
voudrait dire cesser semaine là le
gouvernement ça allait parler de
vacances pour les élèves de repos de
courte distance
il ya beaucoup de parents qui ont un peu
grincer des dents dans ce parce que des
vacances pour les enfants pendant deux
semaines ça veut aussi dire qu'on
travaille à la maison pour moi plus
compliqué pourquoi sonner son est obligé
de faire des cours à distance assez
souvent pourquoi le soudainement on
pourrait plus faire des cours à distance
en janvier et beaucoup de zones à
éclaircir le policier indique à qui ce
qui saute pas de joie non plus qu'à être
pas nécessairement christian c'est
normal qu'ils aient des tâtonnements
vendant l'arrivée des décisions mais il
ya quand même des dommages qui sont
causés par sos d'abord les parents on
peut comprendre c'est très concret qui
ont des enfants c'est la gestion de leur
temps et moi ce que je crains c'est que
ça alors ça discrédite un petit peu les
consignes gouvernementales
parce que on arrive avec des
propositions d amendements on ne discute
pas ce matériau donc ça diffuse le fait
que ces consignes ne sont pas
scientifiques comme tel on n'est pas
dans la rigueur et la dans le contexte
de noël je pense qu'on peut être un peu
inquiet parce que noël j'ai eu une
pulsion de vie très forte déjà on semble
que beaucoup de québécois qui sont pas
des conspirations disques because it is
you interprète un peu à leur façon des
consignes actuelles
donc si on est trop dans les
tâtonnements sont inévitables certains
points moi je crains vraiment que le la
santé publique exactement prêts internes
de plus en plus de crédibilité surtout
celle des cascades et ça fait très très
compliqué voilà tu dois dire que je suis
pas un expert là dedans
par moments je me perds les médecins
suivent ça nous on se sent un peu plus
que le meilleur rebondeur flair mais
demandeurs et herpa madeleine une
uniformité partout au canada je le dis
en ontario on a on a télégraphié à le
fait qu'il n'y aura pas de prolongation
des périodes de congés l'abord donc ça
ça ira selon les provinces
généralement le gouvernement fédéral
arrive avec des consignes générales avec
des suggestions qui peuvent être
appliqués par les provinces mais ça
reste à elle à les appliquer
souvenez-vous de la louippe par exemple
y avait la docteure tam qui avait dit
dans certains contextes c'est possible
de passer l'halloween si on essaie de
respecter une distanciation physique et
tout et tout mais ça reste quand même
que c'est les premiers ministres des
provinces qui ont la tâche extrêmement
difficile de prendre une décision parce
que oui on veut sauver noël oui c'est
important d'essayer de garder un peu
d'espoir un peu de vie un peu normal
dans un contexte aussi important que
noël mes yeux tous les effets domino de
ça on a parlé d un des parents qui ont
de la difficulté de travailler parce
qu'ils ont les enfants dans les jambes
mais il ya aussi la réussite scolaire on
en parlait du fait qu'elle est le
décrochage peut augmenter lorsque il ya
moins de jours d'école donc tout ça ça
doit rentrer en ligne de compte donc on
est dans la logique de la réduction des
méfaits qu'est-ce qu'ils vont être le
épine dans l'essai n'a évoqué les propos
de solutions qui vont être parfaite
il va voir la moins pire des solutions
en espérant qu'on doit quand même un
petit peu un petit esprit des fêtes le
24 sera pas parfait pour tout le monde
mais il faut que ça soit parfait pour le
plus a fait mieux pour le plus de monde
possible
en fait c'est ce qu'on souhaite alors à
suivre on devrait avoir des annonces
cette semaine là dessus le français
alors sa madeleine
ça chauffait aujourd'hui à ottawa une
histoire qui remonte à quelques jours
pour bien la comprendre
geo faire entendre le premier extrait de
cette député de la région de montréal
madame nombreux pilotes qui
s'interrogeait dans le fond ce que le
france est vraiment menacée parce que
c'est pas un mythe tout son écoute sort
on va écouter des réactions convient
après l'accord de m
présidant la députée de saint laurent a
été très méprisante envers les
francophones portant aucune député
libéral de québec ne l'a dénoncé ces
députés nos fonds rayé pour défendre le
français si le chef de l'opposition veut
démontrer son engagement envers le
français
est-ce qu'ils s'engagent aujourd'hui à
ne nommer que des juges bilingues à la
cour suprême du canada
nous regrettons les propos de la députée
diane de selliers excellent bas pardon à
saint laurent a et on est content
qu'elle se soit excusé pour ses propos
alors ça c'est pour madame labro poulos
puis on va entendre monsieur blanchet
dans une seconde mais d'abord lorsqu'il
a ajouté de l'huile sur le feu madeleine
c'est que la présidente du parti libéral
du canada section québec a dit dans un
tweet le 11 septembre que c'était la loi
sa revalorisation est une une loi hope
racing d'une loi oppressif qui a ruiné
l'éducation en anglais au québec tout à
fait une analyse qui passe très bien au
québec
elle s'est reprise ça a disparu ce
triple a et elle s'est repris
aujourd'hui en disant on doit le voir
l'inversion avait changé donc ça c'est
le madame craig voilà elle lady
aujourd'hui je veux être clair le
français recule au québec il faut le
protéger la loi 101 est importante
c'est important pour eux de pouvoir se
faire servir en français au québec
incluant montréal
bref madeleine il a fallu quelques
pédales par en arrière et ça a mis
beaucoup de pression sur les libéraux
oui justement parce que ça fait
plusieurs jours en fait que cette
histoire dure et l'opposition essaie de
dire que le cas de madame lambrot poulos
dans saint laurent ce n'est pas un cas
isolé que c'est pas une députée qui a
dit ça finalement qui est une classe à
part ce que tentait de faire
l'opposition c'est de dire elle dit tout
haut ce que d'autres au sein du parti
libéral pensent tout bas
donc le fait d'avoir creusé et trouver
d'autres finalement propos qui ce qui
passe pas bien publiquement comme celui
de la présidente du parti libéral au
québec du parti libéral du canada au
québec bien ça vient finalement un peu
de donner des arguments à l'opposition
l'opposition qui étaient parfois en
position défensive notamment les
conservateurs souvenez-vous les libéraux
avec toute l'histoire de d'oxford
décompression des services en français
en ontario
les libéraux s'étaient attaqués à un joe
chirales époque là dessus essayant de
les placer sur la défensive donc la
langue devenait une arme pour le parti
libéral
et ce sont eux maintenant je suis
retourné ça s'est retourné contre le cri
quelques jours qu'en pensez-vous du
touchant d'abord qui a beaucoup de
députés et de ministres libéraux qui
sont en furie
parce que j'ai parlé à certains - dans
les derniers jours qu'ils disent d'abord
c'est contraire à la position même du
parti c'est écrit noir sur blanc dans
discours du trône il faut protéger
davantage le français au québec
il faut revoir la loi sur les langues
officielles notamment parce que le
québec à l'extérieur du québec mais même
au québec est en déclin donc la position
officielle du parti n'est pas celle du
manuel abreu poulet ou de la présidente
du parti libéral du canada au québec
alors ça mais bien des députés peu en
furie contre le manque de jugement de
leurs collègues
et du fait que on vit peut-être chez ces
personnes là dans lequel madame craig
dans le cas de madame nombreux pilotes
dans un un autre montréal de montréal
peu plus anglophones on n'a pas besoin
véritablement d'interagir avec tes la
langue française alors on y vote de
spéculation d'opinion personnelle qui ne
sont pas nécessairement rattaché à la
réalité ça ça dérange bien des libéraux
oui l'opposition est en furie mais je
peux vous et quel prix les libéraux ont
pu réussi d'abord ça au moment où au
québec on le sent dans les prochains
mois si mon jeu les barrettes va déposer
sa réforme la charte de la langue
française va y avoir des discussions
avec ottawa des demandes des
revendications sa place le gouvernement
trudeau dans une position délicate à la
proche de cette discussion là avec
québec
alors serait pas la sphère de pudeur
mélanie joly est sorti assez durement
contre sa collègue dans les dernières
heures en disant que c'était points en
septembre et elles étaient abasourdis
blessure dit oui mais ça voisin de
circonscription est alors passé son
après madame joly s'est dit abasourdi
effectivement christian si elle pense
moi j'ai pas aimé qu'elle le dise mais
ça représente une partie de la réalité
c'est vrai puis une partie des québécois
actuellement qu'on occupe honda tâche
trop d'importance là on va les
accompagner cet euro le bon côté de la
fin c'est que ça a mené quand même au
niveau fédéral des personnages
importants à admettre que le français
était en difficulté au québec qui est
bon et ça c'est quand même assez nouveau
une espèce d' approche appuyant
violentes à l'égard de croissance et
c'est très anciens sont dégustés
familles ont à l'époque je dis que la
loi était grande et canadien donc ça
c'est pas nouveau ce que moi ce que je
trouve qu'ils nous volent c'est que des
gens pour les na'vi jeudi 10 et non
c'est pas vrai le français avec des
soins québec même et même justin trudeau
bon vivant que c'était très important
que le québec
la question qu'il faut se poser c'est
bien beau les paroles l'appui les
espèces de chicanes partisane est membre
faire quelque chose dans le français
juste un coup d'oeil bien bon des belles
paroles
vous auriez belles paroles leurs gardes
en irak dont la vigueur des autochtones
des groupes ethniques tout le monde
si ottawa on croit vraiment que le
québec est en régression inacceptable au
québec qu'est ce qu'ils vont faire
si c'est la question qu'on se pose là
messieurs
l'enchère s'est emparé du ballon
évidemment pour lui c'était le but était
ouvert
pis il dit voici ce que moi je propose
on va écouter geof une chance geof une
chance au parti si libéral de faire plus
que de la pide aux titres de bouc
émissaire de bouc émissaire pardon
madame landreau klaus demain le bloc
québécois va déposer une loi qui ferait
en sorte que quelqu'un qui demande de
statut de citoyen canadien à partir du
québec doivent de montrer une
connaissance adéquate du français voient
la madeleine bon ils vont le déposer sa
mère ont peut-être pas très loin mais ça
a permis au bloc québécois de de prendre
la parole la tulle oui encore une fois
c'est un sujet qui est vraiment très
cher aux particuliers au bloc québécois
ça lui permet de revenir sur une
question identitaire c'était onu le même
scénario il ya quelques semaines avec
toute la question du racisme les mots en
aide tout ça à chaque fois on dirait que
le parti libéral a de la difficulté à se
sortir de ces dossiers là et le bloc
québécois est très bon pour prendre la
balle au bond le parti libéral a aussi
une solution
c'est à dire d'offrir un statut
particulier pour le québec pour défendre
le français même au québec parce que
pour le moment il ya la loi sur les
langues officielles qui est incertain
mais c'est finalement un pacte lotion on
veut mon protège l'anglais au québec et
on protège le français en milieu
minoritaire
or québec alors que lieu le gouvernement
libéral dit maintenant il faudrait vu
son statut minoritaire en amérique du
nord
protéger le français aussi au québec
mais effectivement comme christian le
dit pour le moment ce sont des maux
solution aux maux qui sont dans ce cas
du trône est ce que ça va se concrétiser
dans les prochains mois
là il ya de la pression supplémentaire
sur l'inclusion
conclusion christian les i et 30
secondes chacun commence a pu se
concrétiser ce droit ou à la fois joueur
fait aux données qui montrent qu'on a
des difficultés parfois se faire servir
en français à montréal
donc c'est très bon premier ministre
sinon je les bats avec dont on attend en
fait des mesures vigoureuses et
efficacement en termes de français je
trouve ça crée un contexte où il ya
comme une espèce de consensus à l'effet
qu'un problème c'est qu'on fait ça oui
lui le contexte va changer pour lui pour
le mieux effectivement alec je pense que
ça donne des munitions à mélanie joly et
à ses alliés à l'intérieur du parti
libéral qui pousse auprès du premier
ministre qui poussent leurs collègues
anglophones aussi pour avoir quelque
chose d'assez musclé comme réforme de la
loi sur les langues officielles ils ont
l'occasion de faire du judo avec cette
controverse la mise en garde et leur
maintenant faut être sérieux pour
arriver avec quelque chose de bon les
paroles ne suffit pas donc si on est
capable chez les libéraux d'utiliser
salle à leur avantage peut-être que ça
pourrait donner quelque chose
d'intéressant intéressant de vous
entendre merci a bientot vous trois au
revoir merci